wir zeigen ihnen gleich bilder die erst
wenige wochen alt sind noch mit belebten
straßen und mittlerweile frauen und
kinder vor allen dingen eben genau dort
nicht live auf diese straßen jetzt mit
paul zu dir berichte uns von deinen
ersten eindrücken aus der weg gerade
gesagt hab wohl gefährlichste hauptstadt
im moment der welt
ja ich bin hier an einem checkpoint
mitten in kabul hinter mir siehst du
taliban kämpfer mit ihren waffen die ihr
diesen check point kontrollieren die
immer wieder autos anhalten nach den
papieren natürlich fragen und wissen
wollen wer fährt wohin ihr die straße
muss man sagen ist relativ belebt
ähnlich wie es vor sechs wochen erlebt
habe aber natürlich hat sich die
situation völlig verändert die menschen
das muss man sagen die angst haben und
den vor denen die gerade hinter mir
stehen die verstecken sich vor allem in
ihren wohnungen die warten darauf dass
sie raus geholt werden die ort kräfte
die dann irgendwie schon pakistan lustig
ist dann über den landweg jetzt raus
müssen
weil wir sehen sie bilder hinter dir
eine wirklich bedrohliche situation man
kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen auch
wie die menschen mit diesem alltag leben
beschreiben es einmal was in ihren
gesichtern sie ist wie die menschen
darum gehen du hattest gesagt man sieht
auch überhaupt keine frauen mehr wie ist
es jetzt in kabul ist das anders als zu
dem was du während einer stundenlangen
fahrt auf den dörfern gesehen hast
kabul es anders als die dörfer die wir
gesehen haben ich habe hier sehr wohl
frauen auf der straße gesehen und sich
nicht auch nicht alle erhöhen sondern
noch nicht nur zusagen dem komplett
angepasst was ja die taliban points
allerdings ist weniger als die sechs
wochen gesehen habe muss ich sagen was
gibts ja die menschen versuchen sich
anzupassen
die müssen überleben das ist das worum
es hier geht und wenn ich mit ihnen
spreche dann haben sie natürlich angst
sie würden jetzt aber offen der staat
nicht kritische sagen ja gegen ihre
neuen herrscher die sie ja im griff
haben ich über ihr leben bestimmen über
leben oder tod bestimmen können das
meistens wenn ich dann menschen ihr
frage höre ich nein das ist schon in
ordnung die regierung hat viel falsch
gemacht jetzt versuchen wir es eben mit
den taliban das ist das was die menschen
sagen und die taliban selbst sind
profitieren kann man sagen gestern gab
es dir in den straßen das feiern an den
moment als der letzte us-soldat
kabul verlassen habe ich sie hier mal
ganz krassen
militärfahrzeuge
polizeifahrzeuge also die taliban haben
hier alles eingenommen was ist gab nun
kann man ja gar nicht mehr durch das
land reisen und vor allen dingen nicht
in die hauptstadt reisen paul ohne auch
kontakt zu den taliban zu haben du
brauchst die stempel sozusagen in deinen
papieren von den taliban du hast gerade
gesagt du bist da am checkpoint gerade
der taliban wie ist es mit diesen
bärtigen männern in kontakt zu sein in
kontakt sein zu müssen
ich habe das gefühl dass momentan die
taliban tatsächlich presse in gewisser
weise auch suchen also es ist nicht so
dass wir hier
ständig betont werden die sind bereit
auch interviews zu geben ich glaube das
liegt daran eben das nicht momentan als
sieger fühlen wir wissen ja auch dass
die deutsche bundesregierung akkus box
in doha mit diesen taliban eben
gespräche führt darüber dass es wieder
geld eben soll also um die ortskräfte
herauszubekommen aber viele viele
menschen mit denen ich sozusagen im
untergrund schreibe das sind diejenigen
die sich hier nicht auf die straße
trauen die angst haben davor genau so
eine situation wie hinter mir zu erleben
wir sehen sozusagen hier die taliban die
die straße kontrollieren und wir stellen
uns vorjahr in der ortschaft nach
deutschland führt hier durch und dann
fliegt sie auch weil sie auf irgend
einer liste steht und die menschen haben
angst eben vor dieser rache und sie
sagen uns wenn das passieren sollte wenn
du zu sagen sie erwischt werden dann ist
das die taliban selbst sagen wir ich
habe wohin mit einem camper sprechen
können er sagte nein es gibt eine
amnestie wir tun den nichts naja das
glaubst du richtig noch niemand paul ich
kann gar nicht wechseln was bei dir im
hintergrund passiert und er wird mir im
studio hier ehrlich gesagt angst und
bange wir sehen die taliban im
hintergrund die telefonieren lässig in
die waffen darum den körper herum was
sagen diese männer wie wirken die auf
dichte wie wirken so entspannt du
beschreibst hier auch sie sind
sieges freudig feiern hat man bei denen
das gefühl das kann sich aber
schlagartig ist von sekunde zu sekunde
auch wieder ändern
von sekunde zu sekunde glaube ich nicht
patricia und das liegt einfach daran
dass sie sich momentan als sieger fühlen
dass sie mit der bundesregierung
offiziell verhandelt dass der größten
traum dieser menschen ja wahr geworden
ist muss sich das so vorstellen ja
generationen gegen uns in den westen
gekämpft natürlich auch gegen die
afghanische regierung und jetzt
kontrollieren sie hier hinter mir die
straßen von kabul punkt die das anders
sind die jungen männer die ich noch vor
wenigen wochen in ladakh der provinz
getroffen hat die sind jetzt hier in
kabul also warum sollten die momentan
eine schlechte stimmung haben oder mir
gegen pakistan das tun sie nicht aber
natürlich kann sich das in wochen in
monaten ändern wenn sich die westliche
politik ändern sollte und natürlich ist
es für diejenigen gefährlich nicht mit
deutschen zusammen gearbeitet haben mit
amerikanern zusammengearbeitet haben für
die ist das eine ganz andere
paul du hast ja immer es wirklich sehr
bemerkenswert ist auch viele kontakte zu
den taliban wie sprechen sie über den
westen
sie sprechen momentan nur gut über den
besten sie sagen richtig gut dass die
bundeswehr abgezogen ist endlich seid
ihr beck aus unserem land das ist das
einzig gute was sie tun konnte und
übrigens wir wollen gute diplomatische
beziehung mit euch das wird mir immer
wieder gesagt wir wollen mit deutschland
ein gutes verhältnis aber klaus das
wollen sie natürlich nur so lange wie
wir uns nicht einmischen wie wir brav
die millionen hier überweisen das ja
mehr oder weniger schon angekündigt
wurde von heiko maas dem deutschen
außenminister solange wir nichts sagen
wenn ihr jetzt
passieren wenn menschen gelyncht werden
wenn frauen eingesperrt werden und das
ist das was sie taktisch muss man sagen
ganz gut machen egal mit wem man spricht
alle sprechen hier über eine amnestie
und darüber dass den ort hätte nicht
passieren sollen nur die ortskräfte
haben eine ganz ganz große an wir haben
paul von dir auch bilder bekommen die ja
viele menschen vor geschlossenen banken
zeigen menschen die versuchen in dieser
situation dringend an ihr geld
ranzukommen im geld abzuheben die banken
sind geschlossen die warten da und wer
nicht in der schlange sauber geordnet
steht der wird mit schlägen traktiert
diese bilder hast du uns gezeigt wir
können sie gleich mal einspielen paul
kleber oder zeige uns beschreiben mit
deinen worten was du in diesen straßen
da erlebt hast und ja welche note haben
die menschen gerade wenn sie ja sich in
solche schlangen begeben nur um eben an
ihr geld ranzukommen
ja es ist eine knallharte law & order
politiker aber nicht so wie wir sie
vielleicht können von politikern sondern
tatsächlich eben angelehnt an die
radikal islamischen scharia damit
geschlagen da wird draufgehauen wenn man
sich nicht dementsprechend verhält wie
den taliban das wollen und natürlich
freuen sie auch aktive hart bestrafen so
sagen sie immer wieder das handabhacken
halt der islamischen scharia also sie
wollen hier einen schreckens
zeigen und den leuten zeigen dass die
sich nicht definieren sollen das ist das
was sozusagen von den taliban kommt was
immer wieder gesagt wurde und was sie
hier auch anwenden wollen was die
wirtschaftlichen situation angeht muss
man sagen kann ist katastrophal weil
hilft eingefroren sind in die banken
haben zu wenig bargeld nur teilweise
geöffnet wir wissen dass lebensmittel
langsam knapp werden also ich jetzt
droht neben dem ganzen was du hier
hinter mir erlebt neben der angst die
viele menschen haben durch diese neuen
regeln hier auf der straße bis brot auch
eine humanitäre katastrophe
paul was hast du so in den nächsten
tagen vor wie frei kannst du dich in
dieser stadt bewegen also man merkt auch
in unserem gespräch du drehst die zur
sicherheit doch auch immer mal wieder um
und schaust was die taliban hinter dir
so machen wir haben ja auch ein bisschen
manchmal neugierig in die kamera
geschaut sondern sich jetzt der
hinterlegen gesetzt wie frei kannst du
dich in der stadt bewegen und wie hast
du auch diese nacht jetzt in dieser
stadt verbracht macht man da überhaupt
ein auge zu
martin zu ehrlich gesagt bin ich so
viele tage durchgefahren die haben kein
russland war ja da und dort bin ich nach
moskau von boston nach das stimmt das
ist usbekistan von herstellern zwölf
stunden des termes alles im auto konzern
bis über die grenze nach afghanistan
also ich wusste gar nicht mehr gestern
aber nicht dass der mal geschlafen hat
und daher habe ich dann richtig schlafen
können was die situation mit den taliban
angeht muss ich sagen bislang gab es
keine störung für uns beim arbeiten
sogar waren sie bereit ich filme zu
lassen interviews zu führen das gab es
bislang für mich keine probleme ich weiß
nicht wie lange das so ist ich weiß
nicht was passiert in den nächsten tagen
wochen aber momentan ist die situation
so dass wir berichten können wir wurden
bisher noch nicht in irgendeiner form
auf irgendetwas hingewiesen was wir
nicht tun sollten sondern wir sind frei
du siehst stehen hier vor dem checkpoint
auf den taliban lassen sich schon auf
das ja relativ absurd muss man sagen
wenn man den geschichten der taliban
kämpft dass da ja profilen jahren
komplett verboten waren und augen einige
smartphones nicht so verbreitet dass das
sich jetzt auch komplett verändert
paul ist ein eindruck dass die taliban
ein
homogener verband sind das also
sozusagen das was ihre unterhändler
versprechen auch durch getragen wird bis
zum letzten soldaten oder ist es eher
ein zusammengewürfelter haufen von dem
man auch sorgen haben muss dass sich da
eigendynamik entwickeln
man muss große sorgen haben glaubt dass
ich dort eigendynamik entwickeln sagte
einer der bei den taliban ist und er
zudem lagert dann sagt du bist mit den
besten verhandeln wir müssen jetzt eine
regierung aufstellen er sagte aber wir
müssen aufpassen nicht zu moderat zu
werden weil ansonsten teile unserer
anhänger dichtung einzels abwandern also
der islamische staat hier in gewisser
weise auch in ihrer radikalität in der
konkurrenz stehen und das ist genau die
herausforderung von den taliban stehen
oder auf der einen seite derwesten sagt
ihr müsst um zu sagen auch leute aus der
regierung auf der alten regierung
mitnehmen und andere die sagen nein wir
wollen hier unseren terrorstaat unseren
schlechten start und wir wollen auch das
tun was wir immer tun wollte nämlich
rache nehmen und die gefahr ist absolut
behandeln das war ein purer vielleicht
sagt nein nein es gibt abende steve aber
dass sich dann hoch und lösen und sagen
wir gehen jetzt von haus zu haus wir
machen jetzt jagt es geht mir noch
einmal um die ortskräfte diese
sogenannten paul über die hat die
kanzlerin ja gestern gesagt na ja das
sind so 10.000 bis 40.000 doch die sich
im land weiterhin befinden in
afghanistan die wir eigentlich hätten
aus fliegen wollen so merkel gestern in
ihrer pressekonferenz kannst du uns
einen hinweis geben wo sind die im
moment wo verstecken sie sich leben die
in kabul sind die wir aufs ganze land
verteilt wer sind wir und wo sind und wo
sind sie
viele der ortskräfte haben sich
tatsächlich versteckt in kabul in
wohnung in die metropole ist
unübersichtlich aber natürlich ist es
trotzdem eine gefahr dass sie dort
gefunden werden einzelne sind auch schon
im land unterwegs oder eine große anzahl
ich habe gestern auf dem weg zum
beispiel jemanden getroffen der aus
kundus kam mit seiner ganzen familie für
die amerikaner gearbeitet hat und jetzt
große große sorgen hat dass er nicht
mehr aus dem land kommt also zum einen
gibt es versteckte hier in der
hauptstadt da gibt es dann wie versucht
sozusagen von internationalen von
deutschland von europa von den usa sie
auf dem weg zum beispiel nach pakistan
oder usbekistan zu bekommen und dann
gibt es leute die das auf eigene faust
versuchen aber der skandal ist ja
eigentlich dass wir nicht mal wissen wie
viele ortskräfte wir haben dass das nie
jemand irgendwo ausgeschrieben hat dass
wir keine nummern haben und dass die
kanzlerin dann einfach mal an dental in
den raum stellen und er sind keine
ahnung hat ob sie stimmen
vorwiegend für dich jetzt die nächsten
tage weiter was hast du four mit wem
willst zu sprechen wie bewegst du dich
jetzt in dieser stadt die helfen ja auch
kontakte dabei dennoch so ganz frei ist
das arbeiten in einer so gefährlichen
situation ja auch nicht
das kind ja wir werden versuchen
natürlich auch mit menschen die in
führenden positionen bei den taliban und
dem weg in einem interview zu bekommen
das weiß man nie wie schnell das geht
wie schnell das definieren wir werden
aber auch versuchen mit denen irgendwie
kontakt aufzunehmen da muss man
natürlich ein großes große vorsicht
walten lassen die sich verstecken also
die ortskräfte die angst haben hier
rauszukommen die beiden seiten und dann
natürlich das leben in der stadt denn
eins darf man ja nicht vergessen es geht
hier um die afghanen wie überleben sie
wie geht es weiter wie kommt die nahrung
ein was ist mit dem geld auch dass in
fragen wie wir fünf beleuchten wollen
und die uns mir und jetzt darf es beim
kameramann der so mutig immerhin mit
aufweisen geht wie uns sehr wichtig dann
kann euch beiden paul ronzheimer live
aus kabul nach na ja sehr beschwerlichen
einreise und nach der beschwerlichen
reise quer durch das land ungefähr 500
kilometer 14 stunden hast du uns heute
früh gesagt paul und du bist ja gestern
abend oben ungefähr 22 uhr in der
hauptstadt der gefährlichsten der welt
angekommen und schilder soll es jetzt
dort diese ersten eindrücke aus kabul
danke dafür heister fläche auf
machen wir
bei uns im studio weiterhin bild lei
chef claus strunz klaus wenn du siehst
wie paul ich muss sagen ich konnte
wirklich gar nicht wegsehen wie hinter
ihm die taliban betont lässig da auf und
ab schritten mit dem handy telefonierend
zu lassen vielleicht sogar fast stolz
darauf sind da ist jetzt die welt sieht
uns und gleichzeitig wissen wir wie das
volk wie die menschen dort behandelt
werden was ging dir durch den kopf wenn
du auch unseren reporter dazu naja das
ist sozusagen eine trügerische
atmosphäre ist die aber sozusagen die
die insignien der sind was man nicht
sehen soll zeigen nämlich bewaffnete
junge männer die aufpassen dass alles so
zu sagen so vor sich geht wie es die
taliban wollen paul ist ja einer der
wenigen journalisten
überhaupt in kabul aus der westlichen
welt wenn ich das richtig sehe es heißt
paul und zweimal ist der draht zur
wirklichkeit er ist derjenige der als
einer der wenigen beschreiben kann wie
es dort wirklich zugeht und diese
diskrepanz zwischen dem wie es wirklich
zugeht und was die politik uns glauben
machen will was dort vor sich geht das
finde ich eines der wichtigsten
journalistischen eine der wichtigsten
journalistischen aufgaben des
aufzuzeigen
es ist da kann ich mich auch nicht nach
so vielen jahren journalismus
freisprechen
gänsehaut moment wenn jemand dort steht
wo eigentlich die hölle ist
[Musik]